[Musique]
le département de la réunion les
responsables d'action d'ordre social
économique culturel et environnemental
pour un budget annuel de 1,6 milliard
d'euros
ce sont près de 5000 agents territoriaux
qui oeuvrent au service des
réunionnaises et des réunionnais au sein
de 400 sites délocalisés sur l'ensemble
du territoire
[Musique]
l'accompagnement de la petite enfance
prend en charge la protection maternelle
infantile
le shaq marmailles et la protection de
l'enfance sur le territoire le
département gère 30 sites de pmi qui
reçoit 15 mille huit cents familles en
consultation médicale 1642 assistants
maternels sont agréés et propose cinq
mille cent vingt places d'accueil 5061
enfants ont bénéficié du chèque
marmaille 877 assistants familiaux sont
agréés pour 2004 places dédiées et 2250
trois enfants ont été accueillis au
titre de la protection de l'enfance la
compétence de l'enfance représente un
budget total de 115,2 157 millions
d'euros et un accompagnement effectifs
2118 agents
[Musique]
la prise en charge du handicap par le
département comprend la prestation de
compensation du handicap
l'accueil familial l'accueil en
établissement l'accompagnement
individuel et le soutien aux structures
d'accompagnement 5245 personnes sont
bénéficiaires de la prestation
compensatrice des handicaps 1369 places
en établissements sont disponibles 1045
aides ménagères et 29 1230 pasquasy re
et pass transport ont été attribués la
compétence de la prise en charge du
handicap représentent un budget total de
102,2 105 millions d'euros et un
accompagnement effectif de 110 agents
[Musique]
l'accompagnement de nos seniors comprend
comme dispositif la paix à l'accueil
familial
l'accueil en établissement
l'accompagnement individuel et le
soutien aux structures d'accompagnement
15 1879 seniors bénéficient de
l'allocation personnalisée d'autonomie
1744 places sont disponibles en
établissement de 1178 ménagères sont
agréés et 27 1153 chaque santé ont été
attribués aux personnes âgées
cette compétence représente un budget
total de 154,4 198 millions d'euros pour
un effectif de 110 agents le soutien du
département à l'économie réunionnaise et
direct par des financements comme les
travaux sur le réseau routier des
travaux sur le patrimoine
l'achat de fournitures et l'insertion
par l'activité économique
le département a financé 135,4 millions
d'euros de commandes publiques en 2018
soit 11% de plus qu'en 2010 7572
entreprises ont travaillé avec le
département en 2018 et 38% d'entre elles
relèvent du btp les chantiers de la
collectivité sur son patrimoine ont
contribué à la création de 1700 emplois
sur ce secteur trente huit structures
d'insertion soutenu par le département
ou générer la création de 550 emplois le
budget alloué au soutien à l'économie
locale représente 149,4 186 millions
d'euros pour un effectif de 660 9 h la
compétence de la culture et du sport au
sein du département se répartit en trois
grands pôles les pratiques sportives des
activités culturelles et l'animation des
théâtres départementaux
chaque année près de deux cent quarante
mille personnes visitent les huit sites
culturels patrimoniaux du département
141 projets associatifs ont été soutenus
et aux artistes ont pris résidence au
sein de ces équipements
pour ce qui est du sport 50 ligue et 508
clubs sont soutenus financièrement et
380 sportifs de haut niveau ont été
accompagnés le domaine de la culture et
du sport représente un budget total de
7,4 181 millions d'euros pour un
effectif de 210 cet âge
[Musique]
les moyens mis en oeuvre par le
département dans la gestion
environnementale se répartissent selon
la préservation des sites touristiques
la protection des espaces naturels
sensibles et les travaux
environnementaux la collectivité
propriétaire de 3600 95 hectares de
forêts et de 92000 136 hectares
d'espacés départementaux de manioc
chaque année 400 milles pratiquants de
sports nature profitent de ces forêts
150 emplois directs et 650 indirects
sont générés au sein de la filière bois
le budget total alloué à l'environnement
et de 23,9 157 millions d'euros pour un
effectif de 93 agents
le département soutient le développement
de l'agriculture et de l'irrigation par
le soutien à l'agriculture la gestion
des fonds européens et le développement
des réseaux d'irrigation
[Musique]
plus de 90 éleveurs et 1500 producteurs
de fruits et légumes ont été soutenus 50
millions d'euros de financements
européens ont été engagés cette année
sur le programme feader 2014 2020 pour
un taux de réalisation totale de 50 % du
programme de 150 hectares
supplémentaires ont été irrigué et 340
hectares supplémentaires sont dédiés à
l'agriculture
cette compétence représente un budget
total de 55 points 104 millions d'euros
pour un effectif de 118 m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour le département l'accompagnement de
la jeunesse se fait par les bourses la
vie scolaire et l'insertion des chevrons
au sein de 83 collèges publics et privés
à la réunion soixante mille élèves
bénéficient du passeport éducatif
collégiens 500 élèves sont sensibilisés
à la citoyenneté avec le conseil
départemental des jeunes 12 5 millions
d'euros sont investis pour les travaux
de rénovation des établissements 10770
étudiants bénéficient de la bourse
départementale dont 30 % poursuivent
leur cursus de formation en métropole ou
à l'étranger pour l'insertion des jeunes
le département dispose d'une structure
innovante qui est l'académie des dalons
69 jeunes sont accueillis chaque année
au sein de cette structure
deux cent soixante dix sept jeunes sont
aidés pour créer leur activité et 2000
jeunes sont accompagnés par le cna remet
pour leur projet d'insertion
professionnelle hors de la réunion la
compétence de la jeunesse représente un
budget total de 39,8 193 millions
d'euros pour un effectif de 1363 agents
y compris les agents des collèges
[Musique]
la famille et la compétence principale
du département elle comprend le
versement du revenu de solidarité active
le rsa des familles monoparentales
le revenu de solidarité autre maire et
le soutien l'habitat quinze mille deux
cents familles monoparentales et 78500
autres foyers sont bénéficiaires du rsa
590 foyers sont bénéficiaires du rsa
revenu de solidarité outre mer de 1892
foyers sont aidés par le fonds de
solidarité pour le logement et 1500 huit
logements ont été améliorés la
compétence famille représente un budget
global de 651 millions d'euros pour un
effectif de 835 agents
[Musique]